[Music]
let's face it the chicago cubs have been
struggling a little bit
this year and uh i think i know why
i think i know why the cubs are one of
the only teams in professional baseball
without an official mascot
yeah and maybe this was my thought maybe
having a mascot would help break the
curse
so here's what we did
we came up with some really good mascot
options for the cubs you want to see
these
i hope you like them here they are new
cubs mascots
our first mascot is one of the most
famous buildings in chicago that happens
to have an embarrassing personal problem
please welcome the incontinent chicago
water tower
this next mascot
combines chicago's most notorious
gangster with one of science fiction's
most powerful computers please welcome
hal capone
any of you's bombs cross me i'll
murderize you
i control all the booze on the north
side see
i'm a legitimate businessman i tells you
i gots every judge in my back pocket
unbelievably stupid we had
we had to look long and hard for this
next cubs mascot it's the one waitress
in the entire city who has not slept
with cub mark grace give it up for right
here
only one
that hasn't
she slept with them uh
here's the mascot that reflects all the
magic of this year's cub season it's the
cubs better trying to hit a pinata let's
take a look there
yes
and finally
our final mascot combines a chicago
civil rights icon with a pop music icon
it's the jesse jackson 5.
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
incredible
incredible
one man making all that happen